Jordan Peterson is a Harvard and now
University of Toronto professor of
clinical psychology he went from being
born in a small town to a librarian and
school teacher to becoming one of the
world's best known psychologists and
having a YouTube channel with over 2.5
million subscribers need motivation
punch a top-10 the belief nation
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because you are probably
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that push by surrounding
yourself with the best so today let's
learn from one of the best jordan
peterson and my take on his top ten
rules of success enjoy okay let's pick
it off with rule number one have a rule
breaking proclivity you know Silicon
Valley tends to be liberal every
everyone knows that and the reason for
that is that there's a tremendous number
of entrepreneurs there and entrepreneurs
can to be high in openness and lower in
conscientiousness so they're creative
but they're also willing to break rules
you know which you kind of have to do
often hopefully not to a criminal extent
but you have to yeah well you know it's
tricky when you're trying to establish
something new because look at a company
like uber you know they had to bend the
rules to be successful and those
companies that have rented those
scooters out and put them on the streets
everywhere you know they just kind of
went ahead and did it it's not something
an orderly person would do because
they'd ask for permission whereas the
people who started these scooter rental
companies just said well what will
happen if we put them everywhere and the
answer was that seemed to work but you
know you have to have a rule-breaking
proclivity in order to manage that rule
number two
take small steps take a bit of a look at
yourself and think about what's not so
good that you could improve that you
should improve by your own standards and
that you would improve you know and save
yourself a little goal you know maybe
you're not studying at all at at you and
your university or maybe you're maybe
you're at work and you've got this stack
of paper there you know and you haven't
looked at that damn stack for like a
month and you know that you should be
and your boy bothering yourself at night
because you're avoiding that it's like
maybe they go I've avoided that stack of
paper completely for one month I'm quite
a coward when it comes to whatever
snakes might be hidden in that stack of
paper how about tomorrow I just like put
that stack of paper in front of me on my
desk and I like a glance through it for
15 seconds see if I can do that
it's like well you set yourself a goal
of improvement you know it's a humble
goal because really are you such a
coward that the best that you can bloody
well manage after a month of avoidance
is 15 seconds of exposure to a stack of
paper you know it could easily be you've
been avoiding it you're obviously afraid
of it and so the situation could be that
dismal and dire and you might think well
geez it's no bomb to my ego it's no it's
it's no it's not fostering the strength
of my ego to recognize myself someone
who could only withstand 15 seconds of
exposure to that thing I'm afraid of and
so that's a form of humility too it's
like there's things you could do to
improve and you know what they are and
there's small steps that you could take
that you might take that would put you
in that direction and then the question
is are you big enough to take those
small steps you know are you capable of
grappling with the fact that you're
fundamentally flawed to the point where
you have to break things down into
almost childlike steps in order to
manage them and the answer to that is
yeah you are and that's the Lord of I
don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so I would
say to some degree it's the lord of
everyone people vary in the degree to
which they've conquered them and you do
meet people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined but most of
the time they've got disciplined and
exactly this manner it's through slow
incremental improvement and then you
challenge yourself it's like well could
I do this that would be better then you
find out and then you think well is
there something slightly larger and more
challenging that I can do that would be
better and and you try it and you find
out and as you try it and you find out
generally you get better at it and you
can take on larger and larger challenges
rule number three take responsibility in
any case people do waste a lot of time
and they are they also act counter
productively a lot of the time
regardless we do make progress and and
and and we can thrive
under the difficult conditions that make
up our lives and we can resist the
malevolence that entices us that's
within our power and we don't know the
limits to that and we also know that
it's better - we all know this that is
better to live courageously
than cowardly everyone knows that that's
what you teach people that you love and
and we know that it's better to live
truthfully than in deceit and you can
tell that - because that's also what you
tell people that you love and we know
that you should pick up your damn
responsibilities and move forward
everyone knows that it's it's part of
our intrinsic moral nature and that
nature is there and it's not difficult
to communicate to people about this like
everyone knows that you wake up at 3:00
in the morning when you've left let your
life go off the rails and that you
berate yourself for your uselessness and
your cruelty and your failure to take
off to take the opportunities that are
in front of you and if you were the
master in your own house in some sense
the captain of your own destiny
if there is no intrinsic nature well
that would never happen you'd just let
yourself off the hook
there'd be no voice of conscience
tormenting you but no one escapes from
that and what that indicates is to me is
that at least psychologically we live in
a universe that's characterized by a
moral dimension and we understand that
well and that moral failings have
consequences and that they're not
trivial they destroy you they destroy
your family they destroy your community
and and you can tell people that and
they listen because they know they don't
know they know that's the thing and
maybe that's the thing about being in an
Intel
you have the opportunity to articulate
ideas that other people know they embody
but they can't articulate and that's
what people tell me you know they say
well you help me give words to things
that I always knew to be true but
couldn't say or or they say I've been
trying to put some of your precepts into
practice responsibility being a main one
vision another honesty I suppose
bringing up the pack and saying this is
the fun part of doing all of this fun is
a weak word that it's it's it's a it's
the remarkable part of doing all this I
mean I have people tell me constantly
wherever I go it's so delightful
that you know they were in a pretty dark
place and they tell me why there's
plenty of dark places in the world and
they decided well maybe they were gonna
develop a bit of a vision and take a bit
more responsibility and start telling
the truth and putting some effort into
something and they come up and they say
well you can't believe how much better
things are rule number four be
persistent if you really want to solve a
complicated problem maybe you tried to
solve it a hundred ways and then you
take the best solution got it look this
happens to entrepreneurs all the time -
you know most entrepreneurs this is
something to know what most
entrepreneurs most creative people fail
at producing their creative product and
monetizing it right so your default
position if you're a creative person is
you're gonna fail and so and that's
because it's hard to come up with
something new and it's a and it's hard
to present it to the market at the right
time and it's hard to market it like
those things are really really difficult
and so what successful entrepreneurs do
is they just keep doing it over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and eventually if they're fortunate
one of their ideas happens to hit the
right place at the right time and so
that's also dark Darwinian in some sense
you know you're creating all these
little enterprises that are sort of
alive
they're run by people after all and even
if your idea is good that doesn't mean
it will be successful there's so many
things that have to be taken into
account so this is partly why
persistence and that's part of
conscientiousness is so useful it's like
you know what are they safe if at first
you fail then try try again and and that
would probably mean try something
different rather than the same thing but
persistence is helpful because it
enables you to run many many experiments
and and you need to know that the
baseline is failure you know it's
important because otherwise you'll blame
that on yourself also if you want to
have more confidence in self-love check
out my 254 series where every day for
the next 254 days I'll send you a free
video to your email that's unlisted to
help you move your confidence forward
the links to sign up are in the
description below if you're gonna speak
effectively you have to know way more
than you're talking about you have to
treat yourself like you matter because
if you don't then you don't take care of
yourself and you become vengeful oh no
you're okay you should feel good about
yourself like you're fine the way you
are it's like you think well that's a
calming message for people it's like no
it's not rule number five commit I would
say for the last 45 years we've told
psychologists have been have been
certainly to blame for this at least in
part you're OK the way you are that's
what we tell young people oh you're okay
the way you are it's like there's
nothing worse than you can tell that you
can tell someone who's young than that
especially if they're miserable you know
and lots of them law if they're
miserable and aimless it's like oh I'm
miserable and aimless and sometimes I'm
suicidal and I'm nya list ik and I don't
have any direction in your life it's in
my life it's like well you're okay the
way you are here and it's like they
don't want to hear that they want to
hear look you know you're and you know
this you're useless
you know nothing you haven't got started
you've got 60 years to put yourself
together and god only knows what you
could become and that's so that message
is so much more it's so funny because
it's so
it's such an attack but it's so positive
because there's faith there in the in
the potential that makes up the person
rather than the miserable actuality that
happens to be manifesting itself at the
moment and young people respond
extraordinarily well to that because
well you know that if you're a parent
and you love your your child your son
your daughter what you're trying to
foster is the best in them you want that
to manifest itself across the course of
their life you want them to become
continually more than they are to see
what they could be and well and I think
that's part of the great message of the
West is that that's that's the that's
the ethical requirement of individual
being in in in the proper sense is to
constantly note that you're not what you
could be to take responsibility for that
and to and to commit yourself like body
and soul to the attainment of that ideal
rule number six don't compare to others
well the first thing I think you need to
understand is that these people that
you're comparing yourself to you don't
really know very well you know and what
that means is that you see their shiny
outside but you don't see the reality of
their life and so what your
[Applause]
you know maybe you're in California see
someone speeding down the road in a in a
convertible Porsche and you think oh man
what a lucky bastard and the truth of
the matter is that he's thinking about
wrapping his expensive sports car around
the next cement pillar that he comes
close to you know you can't tell and
people have hard lives and and even
people who are comparatively fortunate
have hard lives and so the the ideal
that you're observing that makes you
jealous and resentful is in large part
an illusion that's created by your own
mind and
[Applause]
you know I can give you just one example
I like I know a fair number of extremely
wealthy people and most of them most of
the people I happen to know are people
who've made them their money themselves
and I tell you man they have a burden of
responsibility that would would crush me
but would crush the typical person
they're just work and flat out like 90
hours a week and they have thousands of
people depending on them and you know
they have their money and and they have
their status and that's not nothing
but don't be thinking that there isn't a
price to be paid for that you know they
don't see their families they're often
divorced they don't see their children
grow up and and they don't have time off
now there are wealthy what would you
call playboy types I suppose who live
out the dreams of wealth of a foolish
14-year old but they're not that common
and you have to be careful of what
you're jealous of because you don't
really know what it is and then the
other thing that's kind of useful is to
well to understand that you're different
from everyone else and this is
especially true as you get older when
when you're 17 or 16 or something like
that comparing yourself to other people
makes a certain amount of sense because
16 and 17-year olds they're kind of the
same you know which is why when you go
off to university you can make friends
so quickly it's like I'm just about 60
it takes me like 15 years to make a
friend now you know as opposed to the
two months that it took when I was 17
you're you're quite different from other
people and you shouldn't be comparing
yourself to them because they're not
like you you know they don't have your
family they don't have your temperament
they don't have your troubles they don't
have your abilities
the only person that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
the only the only person that has those
is you and this is why one of the rules
I think it's rule 4 is compare yourself
to who you were yesterday and not to who
someone else is today and see that's a
game you can win because you could be a
little better today than you were
yesterday
and that's a good thing you're a little
better that that's a good thing and and
you know no doubt there are some things
that you could improve you know if you
if you sit meditate for any length of
time about what you're not doing
optimally answers will spring to mind
rule number seven be humble you have to
be humble and wise enough to understand
that you might have to aim pretty damn
low especially in those places where
you're not functioning well and it might
be so embarrassing that you can't even
that you can't bring yourself to fathom
that that's actually who you are but you
know you described the fool the
archetypal figure of the trickster in
the fool as the precursor to the Savior
to the Redeemer and that's unbelievable
bit of wisdom because what young meant
was that to put yourself together which
is to follow the path of redemption to
follow the Redeemer
if the Redeemer is a type of personality
that you could in fact be inhabited by
our manifest then this first step
towards that is to allow yourself to be
a fool right it's because you don't know
what you're doing you have to admit that
and there's going to be a loss of ego or
destruction of ego arrogant ego that
necessarily accompanies that but you
need the loss of that arrogant ego
because it's precisely what's
interfering with your movement forward
you know it's part of the adversarial
process mythologically speaking that
stops moral progress you're too proud of
who you think you are to notice what
you're like so that you could change
properly you don't want to sacrifice
that part of yourself it's probably
associated with some delusion that helps
you maintain you know
what would you say a positive although
very fragile self-image you know in the
absence of genuine effort rule number
eight know what you're capable of
you can look at that pessimism that
constitutes let's say the core of what
well I think it's the core religious
message really is the is the tragic
nature of the world the reality of
suffering it's it's part of the core
religious message but what emerges out
of that properly conceptualized is a
remarkable appreciation for what human
beings are capable of like we are
unbelievably resilient and and able
creatures and we do not have any
conception of our upper limits rule
number nine discovered dark parts of
yourself you'll discover a little bit
more about your potential as you
discover who you are especially the
darker parts of yourself because then
you discover your potential for mayhem
there's some real utility in that you
know the discovery that you're dangerous
it's such a useful discovery it's
actually something that strengthens you
because the first thing that a
realization like that can in fact
produce is the the ambition to
incorporate that danger into a
higher-order personality that
dangerousness into a higher-order
personality and that can make you
implacable I can make you someone who
can say no when you need to say no you
know that can make you someone who won't
avoid necessary conflict and so that's
unbelievably useful and will number 10
the last one before a very special bonus
clip is learn from failures when you're
moving through life and you have a plan
or a dream and it shatters you know
someone dies or a relationship breaks
apart or you you have a terrible upset
in your career or you become ill in some
unexpected way then everything around
you falls apart and you plunge into a
wall you plunge into a chaotic
underbelly of the way exactly right yes
exactly that and then
maybe you stay there because it isn't
necessarily the case that people get out
you know people die people are in
despair permanently but frequently
something tragic and terrible befalls
you and you fall apart and you learn
something profound as a consequence and
you put yourself back together and when
you come back out
you're more than you were when you went
in and that's happening in a small scale
every time you learn something you know
you if you ever really learned something
it's usually painful it usually means
that you have to recognize that you're
wrong in some important way you have to
let that part of you that's wrong die
and then you have to let a new part of
you okay so the self imagine that you
undergo a series of transformations in
your life they're they're collapses into
the chaotic underworld and then ret mini
resurrections that happens continually
and that's what molds your character now
I've got a really special bonus clip
that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that if you're still here
watching I want to celebrate you if you
commit to taking action after watching
this video we don't just watch videos we
do something about it
give me a hashtag believed on the
comments as well we didn't understand
that truth comes in different forms
depending on its application it's a
tricky thing there's the truths that
apply when you're attempting to describe
the transformations of the material
world and there's the truths that apply
when you're trying to determine how it
is that you should act while you're
alive and those obviously those have to
come into alignment but they're not in
alignment right now and my sense and
this is a sense that's being developed
at least in part from reading the great
psychoanalysts is that fictional
accounts metafictional accounts even
like biblical accounts which are
mythological are stories about how it is
that people should act not stories about
what the material structure of the world
is
if you want more top ten videos they're
not on this channel anymore I have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and I'll see you
there